Speaker 1: Well, unless you have completely
checked out over the last three days, as I did,
you certainly have heard by now that Donald Trump
claims he will be arrested tomorrow. There has
never been an arrest or indictment of a sitting or
former president in the United States. If Trump is
right, if he's telling the truth, slash correctly
informed, which is still a question mark. This
will be one of the biggest news stories in decades
in the United States and the world, quite frankly.
As the Globe waits to see will Trump be even
potentially held accountable for any of the
myriad things that he did while he was president
and in the lead up during the 2016 campaign? Where
do we even start? Well, let's start with how this
all started with Donald Trump's outrageous all
caps posts riddled with grammatical and spelling
errors to his social media platform. Truth. Social
censure. Call it whatever the hell you want.
Look at the news. And it is news, quite frankly,
that Donald Trump predicted his arrest on that
platform. Let's go right into it. And again,
if you're not if you're listening, these are
these messages are in all capital letters,
which I think is just another one of these little
details. Let's get right into it. Quote, Our
nation is now third world and dying. The American
dream is dead. The radical left anarchists have
stolen our presidential election and with it,
the heart of our our country. I'm reading it as
written, Trump writing Stalin, of course, a famous
German Christmas bread riddled with nuts, spices,
as well as candied or dried fruit. The anarchists
have stolen our presidential election and with it,
the heart of our our country. American patriots
are being arrested and held in captivity like
animals, while criminals and leftist thugs are
allowed to roam the streets. That's not true.
Killing and burning with no retribution. That's
a lie. Millions are flooding through our open
borders and the wrong borders, spelling borders
like if you were a border at a boarding house,
many from prisons and mental institutions. That is
also a lie. The crime and inflation are destroying
our very way of life. Now, illegal leaks from a
corrupt and highly political Manhattan District
Attorney's office, which has allowed new
records to be set in violent crime. Well,
the violent crime rate is higher in Oklahoma
City than it is in New York City. But why let
the facts get in the way of a good all caps rant?
Trump continuing and whose leader is funded by
George Soros, indicate that with no crime being
able to be proven and based on an old and fully
debunked by numerous other prosecutors fairy tale
the far and away leading Republican candidate and
former president of the United States of America
will be arrested on Tuesday of next week. I know
that that's an incoherent word salad, but Trump
is saying they're going to arrest him tomorrow.
Protest, take our nation back, trumps the Trump
demands, and then continuing the calls for protest
and what is increasingly concerningly going to be
a violent protest, which we know Trump supporters
are capable of. Remember January 6th, Trump
posting more. Quote It's time we are a nation
in steep decline being led into World War three
by a crooked politician who doesn't even know
he's alive, but who is surrounded by evil and
sinister people who, based on their actions on
defunding the police. There has been no defunding,
destroying our military. The military is fine.
Open borders. The borders are not open. And no
voter ID? Well, voter ID depends on each state
inflation, which is down. Raising taxes. Biden
hasn't done that. And much more can only hate
our now failing USA. We just can't allow this
anymore. They're killing our nation. As we sit
back and watch, We must save America. Protest,
protest, protest. And then finally, continuing
this morning with these all caps tirades. Quote,
The lead prosecutor for the corrupt Manhattan DA's
office worked as a lawyer for crooked Hillary
Clinton, and her law firm left this Democrat
firm with others to volunteer to, quote, get
Donald Trump at the DA's office for free.
He quit in a huff when D.A. Bragg said there was
no case here. He then unethically and illegally
wrote and published a book about the case while
it was going on. This is unheard of stuff. The
case is now completely compromised and reports
are that Mark Pomerantz is in trouble. This is
all wild stuff. So let me break it down for you
in with clear terms. No president has ever been
arrested nor indicted. Trump claims he will become
the first tomorrow. There have. In two American
presidents subjected to criminal investigations.
Those were Richard Nixon and yes, Donald Trump.
Nixon, of course, resigned from the presidency
before he could be impeached over the Watergate
scandal. And that involved the break in at the
Democratic National Committee headquarters and
the attempts, of course, to cover it up. Nixon was
never indicted, and Trump may be indicted. Trump
could also be wrong and Trump could also be lying.
I believe that this, if it happens politically,
will make Trump stronger. Except if there are
more indictments. I don't believe this case,
which is about Stormy Daniels, is the strongest
case against Trump. However, it's possible,
as we've said before, that prosecutors
are saying to themselves, I have a case.
I have a case against Trump, but I don't want
to be the first to indict, not the first to
indict Trump, the first to indict any former
president. So we may have. At the federal level,
we may have in Georgia, we may have the Tish
James investigation. Remember, this is another
investigation. They may be waiting for another
indictment first to then say, now I'm ready.
I didn't have the testicular fortitude, ovarian
fortitude, whatever term you want to use to be
the first to indict Trump. But I am certainly
willing to be second or third. And this may be
when the levee breaks for our Led Zeppelin fans.
And in that case, I think it will weaken Trump
if it just overwhelms him with criminal cases.
However, I think if this is the only indictment,
it will galvanize Trump supporters and help
him in his Republican primary. We will get to
that later. Let's next talk about how will
MAGA react if Donald Trump is arrested.